[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez bien mangé hier trop manger et
trop bu et maintenant vous avez de la
tête lourde et la langue chargée et vous
vous demandez qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
et bien y avoir des petits remèdes qui
ne valaient aiea le jus de choucroute le
christ a écrasée passe au dessus est ce
que le médicament classique qui consiste
à associer qui veut carbonate de soude
et d'aspirine et efficace et bien oui
le bicarbonate de soude ne fait pas
digérer parce que heureusement on a déjà
digéré mais il augmente les sécrétions
acides de l'estomac et luttent contre
cette impression de bouche pâteuse
quant à l'aspirine et l'autre le mal de
tête par contre des médicaments à base
de plantes ou chimiques que d'aucuns
conseillent d'utiliser au lendemain des
repas important pour dégager la vésicule
biliaire en la faisant se contracter
vieillissante inopportun parce que chez
médicaments s'ils agissent ament un
afflux de bill dans l'intestin comme
l'intestin plein eh bien vous deviner
facilement que le remède risque d'être
pire que le mal
faut-il jeunes et au lendemain d'une
fête et bien les diététiciens disent non
la fête sa fatigue notre organisme a
besoin des apports constituant que sont
ceux de la viande et des vitamines
il faut manger légèrement par exemple
une tranche de jambon rosbif froid
salade ça suffit à maintenir et à
reconstituer et surtout surtout il faut
boire de l'eau beaucoup d'eau l'eau et
le premier est le meilleur des
médicaments contre ce qu'on appelle
vulgairement la gueule de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]